Speaker 1: ny element. Michael Cohen,
whatever you want to say about him,
I find him to be a pretty funny guy. And in
my interactions with him, including privately,
he's been on the show a couple of times.
I've been on his show. He's an all around
good guy and he's genuinely very funny. He
appeared yesterday on MSNBC with Ari MELBER.
He said when asked what's going to happen with
Trump here, he said, Trump. Trump's going to fill
his diaper and he says it completely seriously.
This is nothing other than a comedic interlude.
Speaker 2: Listen to people. We build knowledge. I
can't speak to his mental personal process, but he
is going to learn in a different way through the
primary experience and he entertains the prospect
that he could be convicted and he
could lose his appeals and he could,
at the end of that line, potentially, he's
legally presumed innocent. He could end up
in prison. Based on your long years of service
with him. How will he process them? Very poorly.
You know, as I like to call him sometimes in my
tweets, diaper, Donald will be filling up that
diaper because he this is not something that
Donald is capable of either understanding or
contending with. He, as you stated accurately, he
believes he could control every situation. This
is not a situation that he has any control over.
Right. And that's making him sick to his stomach.
Speaker 1: And I do think that that's a
really interesting thing more generally
with narcissists. And we've talked about this
before. Narcissists believe, among other things,
that they can convince anyone that they're the
smartest and slickest and most clever in the room
and that they can lie and nobody notices. And this
is why with the Mueller probe, Trump wanted to
test, to fire, to be to sit down for questioning,
to be deposed. And his lawyers didn't let him
because Trump thinks I'll just sit down with him.
I'll be able to convince them that I'm telling
the truth, that they won't know I'll be lying.
That is a really common trait of narcissists.
Michael Cohen knows it. It's going to be a wild
48 hours. And I'm glad you're with us for it.